there is something you should know what
there's something I just found out all
of us just found out you're one of a
kind Peter Webber and you set the bar
sky high for the show's future bachelors
Hannah Brown seriously messed up when
she didn't give you that rose but she
may or may not get a chance to make it
up to you
the contestants of season 24 are lucky
to have you as their bachelor but the
same can't be said about some of the
previous season's contestants some of
these ladies competed to win the hearts
of the most despicable bachelors in TV
history pilot Pete might be a stand-up
guy but some of his fellow bachelors put
a stain on The Bachelor name some were
despicable some were pompous and some
were downright boring but there's one
bachelor who was so over-the-top fans
have chosen to forget he ever appeared
on the show the greatest love story
we've ever seen let's kick things off
with Juan Pablo who is one of the most
disliked bachelors of all time one was a
contestant on the ninth season of The
Bachelorette but he was eventually
chosen to be the bachelor of season 18
it didn't take long for both fans and
contestants to realize that Juan Pablo
wasn't exactly husband material
I would never want my children having a
father like you okay for one he wasn't
very supportive and he was constantly
rude to the contestants granted Juan
Pablo did make for a very entertaining
season he was unpredictable and some of
his reactions were laughable Claire
Crowley was the runner-up of season 18
and she was smitten by Juan Pablo up
until he eliminated her in the season
finale problem was Juan Pablo made it
seem like Claire was the girl of his
dreams
Claire refused to hug him at the rose
ceremony and when she left Juan Pablo
remarked that he was glad he didn't pick
her even though he had previously
confessed his love for her but worst of
all Juan Pablo was less than romantic
when he gave Nikki his final rose
he returned her I love you with an I
like you a lot and feel to propose to
her and let's not forget about all the
homophobic comments Juan Pablo made
throughout his run on the show this
despicable bachelor eventually found
love off-camera with Venezuelan model
and TV host Oz Mary L Villalobos
whoo I'm glad in picker are you lyin
dyke junior first made waves as the
runner-up on season 8 of The
Bachelorette then he made a comeback on
the 22nd season of The Bachelor and
things got real messy real quick the
race car driver from the Netherlands
would fall in love with not one but two
of his contestants making for a very
interesting season finale Arie would go
on to marry runner-up Lauren Burnham in
2019 but not before seriously messing
with her head during the season finale
are you proposed to Becca kufran telling
her that his love for her was
unmeasurable he also stated that he
chose her and would choose her every day
from here on out my love for you is
measurable but that was all a lie or at
least a short-lived lunacy because
shortly after the season finale Arie
broke up with Becca
while on camera telling her that he
wanted to get back with Lauren but to
make matters worse it was revealed that
Arie had already contacted Lauren behind
Becca's back to make sure that she would
give him another chance
it all turned out for the best as Arie
and Lauren are now married and have a
little family of their own but still
Arie turned out looking like the bad guy
Emily man everything's gone
I knew that but when I did say one of
the worst bachelors to ever appear on
The Bachelor is hands down Brad Womack
the entrepreneur also happens to be the
only bachelor to ever appear on two
seasons of the show women competed for
his final rose on seasons 11 and 15 and
he outraged the nation when he refused
to propose to either one of his
finalists in season 11 he snubbed both
Deanna Pappas and Jenny Croft during the
season finale but it wasn't his choice
to remain a bachelor that made him
despicable but rather how he chose to go
by it he promised Deanna that the final
rose ceremony would be a good day for
her but it was later revealed that he
had been leading her on for no good
reason
fans were quick to call Brad a jerk and
he even admitted to having made a very
very bad decision but it wouldn't be the
last time Brad treated his contestants
in a nun sock full manner at the end of
season 15 Brad propose to Emily Maynard
however the couple quickly called it
quits and
later revealed that Brad had broken up
with her by sea seeing her in an email
that he'd sent to the show's producers
ouch
we first met Jake Pavelka in season 5 of
The Bachelorette he seemed like the real
deal so after being eliminated in week
six Jake was chosen to be the bachelor
of season 14 ABC executives had high
hopes for Jake the handsome pilot from
Dallas Texas
Jake claimed to be a nice guy but
quickly showed his true colors he stuns
The Bachelor fans everywhere by choosing
to propose to Vienna Girardi in the
season finale this came as a surprise as
it was known that Vienna was the mean
girl of season 14 the couple called off
their engagement in June of 2010 and
soon after Vienna and Jake made
headlines for all the wrong reasons
Vienna went as far as to say that Jake
was emotionally abusive toward her but
be honest accusations became fact when
the former couple sat down with Chris
Harrison to clear the air Jake lost it
on camera when Vienna interrupted him
proving that he could out mean the mean
girl if I don't know you please stop
interrupting me the thing is Sean Lowe
started as a contestant on season 8 of
The Bachelorette and he quickly became a
fan favorite so when he was eliminated
in week 9 ABC didn't hesitate to invite
him to be the bachelor of season 17 now
don't get us wrong Sean isn't the worst
bachelor to ever appear on the show but
we wouldn't go as far as to call him the
best one either
after all Sean was sort of a jerk on
more than one occasion he shamed women
for their outfits and constantly
trash-talked his contestants on Twitter
like that time he bashed one of his
contestants for wearing a bra on the
show it quickly became clear that Sean
had some very backward views he would go
on to give Katherine Gucci his final
rose and the two would get married in
2014 while Katherine found her soul mate
in Sean Lowe other contestants were
happy to have been sent home when it
comes to Sean viewers either hate him or
love him there's no in-between
here's to enjoying the day together I'm
gonna tell them I'm gonna be honest with
him I'm not gonna lie to him if you're a
sucker for reality TV shows like The
Bachelor
hit that subscribe button here at the
things we post daily videos about your
favorite movies TV shows and celebrities
so click that bell to stay in the loop
if you're watching on your mobile or
tablet go into your YouTube settings and
turn on those notifications now let's
get back to the video Oh Benjamin
Higgins you fooled viewers into thinking
you were the perfect guy but it didn't
take long for fans to realize that it
was all an act the software salesman
from Warsaw Indiana first made waves as
a contestant on season 11 of The
Bachelorette he was sent home in week 8
but would resurface in 2016 when he was
named the bachelor of season 20 but
Ben's popularity took a dive when he
began to express a holier-than-thou
attitude so what makes Ben so despicable
well for starters he wasn't always
genuine and he quickly comes off as
calculated then would go on to propose
to Lauren Bushnell during the season
finale but he complicated things by
telling both Lauren and runner-up Jojo
that he was in love with them in the end
viewers aren't too fond of Ben because
he's a crowd pleaser with a hidden
agenda we mean come on he even tried to
launch a political career right after
appearing on the show but that's against
the bachelors rules so his political run
was short-lived hugs all around man
we're taking a trip down memory lane
to bring you one of the most dishonest
bachelors of all time Bob Guiney first
appeared on season 1 of The Bachelorette
and would later become the chosen
bachelor of season 4 however it was
clear that Bob wasn't a hopeless
romantic
despite choosing to be with Estella
cordini a in this season finale he never
proposed to her and they soon broke up
after the season finale aired on TV in
the end Bob just didn't take the show
seriously making him one of the least
liked bachelors of the series I have
come to the realization that I'm gonna
take my time on the dating scene for a
little while like most of ABC's
bachelors Nick viols made his grand
debut on The Bachelorette before being
announced as the next Bachelor Nick was
the runner-up of season 10 but Andi
Dorfman chose Josh Marie over him
Nik would become the bachelor of season
21 and while he wasn't all that bad
viewers quickly got tired of seeing his
face flash across the screen he had a
very dry and sarcastic sense of humor
which often landed him in the hot seat
with some of his contestants while
viewers don't have much reason to hate
him he received way too much exposure
and was deemed annoying by some diehard
bachelor fans but while Nik has always
respected the women on the show he's
proven himself to be a little petty and
condescending Nick would go on to
propose to Vanessa Grimaldi at the end
of season 21 but his heart clearly
wasn't in it so no one was surprised
when the couple called off their
engagement months after the season
finale aired on TV but I want to be real
I don't want to right and right now I
just feel like terrified that's not
going to happen
Jason Mesnick was the man of the hour in
season 13 of The Bachelor but before
appearing on the show he was a
contestant on season 4 of The
Bachelorette just like Nick by all Jason
was the seasons runner-up so ABC figured
that he deserved another chance at true
love the account executive from
Cleveland Ohio was a super nice guy who
treated the women on the show with
respect Jason gave his final rose to
Melissa Rycroft but he quickly regretted
his decision as he was in love with the
runner-up Molly Mulaney Jason broke
things off with Melissa in front of the
camera but the breakup was mutual and
yet Jason still managed to shock and
embarrass Melissa what Melissa didn't
know however was that Jason still loved
Molly he surprised her with that one not
cool Jason not cool I am absolutely in
love with doing it Alex Michelle was the
first bachelor to ever make waves on ABC
but in retrospect he's probably the
worst while he was smart in kind Alex
Agha the women on the show making
viewers more than a little uncomfortable
Alex would go on to give his final rose
to Amanda Marsh an event planner from
Kansas Alex and Amanda dated for about a
year before calling it quits but he
never proposed to her the general
consensus is that Alex was a little
creepy some redditors would even go as
far as to call him a slimeball and for
that reason bachelor fans chose to
forget all about his run on the
show and that's a wrap on the ten most
despicable bachelors in bachelor history
before you go tell us who your top three
favorite and top three least favorite
bachelors are in the comments section
below give this video a big thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe for more
we'll see you next time on the things
thanks for watching